so what i want to do is the following
this shirt here
free will that i have on okay if you can
see this obviously it's not about free
will it's about freeing will smith this
started with the conversation that we
had
uh during dinner which was a bet i think
there was a 100 bet that was made if you
remember you and joe rogan we made a we
made a bet and the bet was what within
12 months
there's going to be a divorce or there's
not going to be divorce right right you
said that there is going to be a doubt i
bet on the hundred dollars
and rogan said no i said no one's
willing to take me on this but he says
i'll bet you let's bet a hundred bucks
right so
so you and robert joe rogan threw down a
lofty 100 dollar bet well i think he can
afford it and i'm gonna i'm gonna show
you guys i can afford it as well but
here here's the point
the point is while we were we were
having a conversation for me it was more
from the standpoint of
that video that came out with jada and
jada bullying will and will say social
media is my bread and butter i don't
appreciate what you're doing right now
and she says you can tell now why we
have issues in our marriage
i think
jada's a bully
i think jada smith pinky jada pinkett
smith is a bully and she's bullied will
and i think this guy has been
sitting behind closed doors do i think
he's done what he's done and had a lot
of fun one million percent do i think
he's done some stuff that's broken
jada's heart one million percent do i
think there's a possibility that jada
has said and used the following words
that if you do anything i'm going to
tell your darkest secrets to the course
of course i'm leaning towards yes yeah
100 i think there would be a red table
conversation throwing will under the bus
maybe i don't know i think there could
happen do i think it would be playing
the victim card you don't know how
difficult it was being married to will i
think so do i think will win on
charlemagne the god the what is that
show uh uh the killer breakfast club and
charlemagne asked him a question saying
hey how does it feel knowing jada will
never love you the way she loved tupac
yeah and he asked the question of will
do i think that bothers him yes do i
think the market's seeing what happened
with augusta is it augusta what's the
guys that might have always thought
obviously yeah so do i think that
bothers him on how the market sees them
yes do i think jada maybe has something
on him with
challenges with maybe men and he had
certain things that he did with men over
the years
i think there's something there but i
think the guy
almost needs to be given permission to
call it quits and move on and he's
afraid to do so so that's why the
hashtag freewill to say well buddy if
you're going through it man somebody
needs to talk because i can guarantee
you here's a challenge somebody asked
joe and i were having a conversation
about have you ever talked to a friend
about having to get a divorce remember
how that conversation went
because i've had those conversations
with a handful of friends but it's only
been a handful of friends and the
conversation goes like this and by the
way
60 of the time when you have that
conversation it backfires on you because
here's how the conversation goes
i had a friend of mine i pulled him
aside and i'm like dude uh
how do i explain this to you
you are an alpha
i've known you for many years you've
always been an alpha but you've turned
into a beta and i look at your face you
hate it because you've compromised your
own values and principles
and it feels like every time i talk to
you're walking on eggshells it feels
like you have handcuffs and shackles
right now and you don't know what to do
next
and i just want to tell you from the
outside i'm not the only person that
notices this okay you need to make a
decision i've had this type of
conversation with men and women before i
get to this point i want to push
therapy i want to push as much go places
go do stuff together but every once in a
while get to this point right
out of the five conversations three of
them guess what happened to it
the individual goes back and tells who
great the wife and and after they tell
their wife what does a wife do don't you
can never talk to the patriarchy you can
never talk to patrick again so the phone
gets pulled you're done yeah right
okay
but the other two
went and processed it
and one of them took the lead in the
family read a book called no more mr
nice guy
and the wife actually responded to him
and said you know what i've been waiting
for this and they've been happily
married till today the other one went
and had the conversation she was not
having it he left her okay
i think
i wonder how many people who are friends
with will have the audacity to give that
advice because they know it's going to
go back to who her virginia and if it
goes to jada what do you think jada's
going to do to that person okay so so
think
you know one time a guy and i were
having a conversation i said listen a
friend of mine i said look why is it
that everything i talked to you about
you go tell your wife it's just my wife
i said do you think that's how it works
yeah yeah so let me get this straight
what book tells you that everything you
tell me you have to go tell your wife i
said do you think everything you tell me
i'll go tell my wife he said well it's
your wife aren't you supposed to do that
i said no that's not how life works yeah
why what's your biggest concern here's
my biggest concern if me and tony are
homies and we're buddies we're best
friends he's married i'm married
he confines in me in something i go tell
my wife three years later my wife and i
get a divorce hypothetically what's her
loyalty to tony this much
yeah did you understand what just
happened is this much loyalty that she
has to tony she doesn't sit there and
worry about what tony's career is going
to be right it's my loyalty to him that
i just lost tony so now tony doesn't
feel comfortable talking to to me
i'm convinced
there's a web
that will is in man i think she has
videos of him getting pounded by dudes
no there has to be something
dude
in it for the black man the name of the
video men in black oh man
that's like well played well stupid
i just i've been
i actually have one real idea that i
think needs to happen
because what i'm getting very sick of is
these
a-list hollywood alpha men getting
emasculated by women
right now the two biggest stories in
hollywood right now
are freaking will smith and jada smith
and johnny depp and amber never heard of
never heard yeah okay and i think what
needs to happen is they need to sit down
in a room and have two mirrors and one
seat in the middle of the mirrors okay
and leonardo freaking dicaprio needs to
say welcome to the room gentlemen no uh
we are in a very elite company right
here we are the biggest a-list stars in
the freaking world and you i want you
both to look at a [ __ ] mirror yeah
you're a will smith yeah you're johnny
freaking them
like just look at them and remember who
you guys are you could do whatever you
want yeah you own the world you're worth
the hundreds of millions and you're just
getting emasculated by these women
taking your money and taking your pride
follow my playbook here for a second
gentlemen you don't have to not get
married out of kids but be a goddamn
pimp yeah maybe i'm doing too much stuff
with freshman fish and rolo these days i
don't know shout out to those guys
but man up will smith yeah man up uh
so man up but but here's the thing let
me tell you what
if you you ever been in a web have you
ever been in a relationship like that
with a woman where you felt like you
have you ever because i've been have you
ever been in of course yeah okay
when you're in it
how oblivious are you yeah you are like
you almost have to be out of it to
notice it yeah who do you know that
hates will smith prior to the slap on
the face and what happened with his zero
you tell me who you've ever met that's
ever hated well
nobody beloved i mean beloved is an
understatement american legend american
legend for a guy to come from his
background and build a story that he's
built people forget fresh prince of
bellerin all these movies he's done all
these major films he's done and he's
going through this so so here's what
we're doing folks if you want to support
this this is what we're doing if you
want to wear this shirt to start the
conversation and post it you can buy
this shirt i'm being serious with you
you can buy this shirt at free
will shirt.com am i saying it correctly
can you put the website so people can't
see it you can buy freewheelshirt.com
we're selling it for 29.99 a hundred
percent of the profits is going to
national institute of mental health
100 beautiful of the profits you can buy
this
and free will pick your size 30 bucks go
all the way to the bottom go all the way
to the bottom go all the way to the
bottom go all the way to the bottom
press no thanks click on that link
national institute of mental health
whatever we sell we're sending all the
money there because i do believe
i do believe will is having certain
mental challenges right now and i'm
telling you i'm convinced his therapist
his friends everybody's afraid of jada
and somebody needs to have this video be
shared with them for him to say you know
what yeah you know i i don't like why
you you know people are talking like
this or he's gonna say maybe this makes
sense okay and by the way yeah i'd love
to see it work out i just think it's way
past the level of it working out it's
time for him tomorrow
joe doesn't think it's gonna work out
joe thinks he's gonna live unhappily
with jada for at least longer than a
year he cannot do that though he's such
a special guy i know but it's been it's
already been a long time yeah you know
what i mean guys like that sometimes
they get in too deep he's he's one was
the best you said at best you surrounded
by yes man what was the date of that
we're gonna know because it was only
april this was early april ufc
jacksonville whenever we got it really
usc and adam you could see his soul like
in that video where she's recording him
you could see his soul is just
appropriate i love that this whole thing
started with a dinner uh
group dinner with yourself first of all
four o'clock what's the name of that
restaurant do you remember cal fort
steakhouse the owner sent me he's a big
fan of the content in jacksonville
unbelievable unbelievable by the way the
wait what was the waiter's name i wish
we could give him a shout out man that
guy is a man she was like the guy spoke
like john bernthal
good i kept telling him you sound like
jon bernthal he had the right voice the
name of the place again calford
c-o-w-f-o-r can you please i'd like to
give these guys a shot i'm starving
right now
by the way
this was in jacksonville i would not
have expected at this quality restaurant
bone marrow okay fogra
oyster any it was the most high quality
we had
anyways it was insane amazing yeah
highly recommended and the owners even a
classier guy
on what they're doing fantastic places
i'd love to go there tonight but it's a
long drive
anyways gang listen if you agree with
what we just talked about in regards to
will just start the discussion
talk about it wherever you want to talk
about it and if you sport the shirt
other people are also going to talk
about 100 is going to go to
national mental health institute is
where the profits are going to go but
last but not least before we wrap up
tony you're performing tonight uh were
you performing tonight miami improv two
shows and two shows tomorrow and uh yeah
i'm on a big tour going up to a bunch of
places tonyhinchcliff.com for tickets if
you enjoyed this short clip click over
here to watch another short clip and if
you want to watch the entire episode the
entire podcast click here
[Music]